los contagios por un micro me escalan
rápidamente en eeuu asia y europa la
variante fue detectada por primera vez
el mes pasado en sudáfrica y otros
países del continente africano y luego
en hong kong y hasta ahora se ha
reportado en 89 países es más contagiosa
que la variante delta y afecta a
personas ya vacunadas o que se han
recuperado del cob y 19
la base de la variante va de una persona
a otra mucho más rápido y a un mayor
número de personas la cifra de contagios
se duplica cada dos o tres días y es por
eso que vemos el brote y eso lo hace tan
particular comparada con las horas
anteriores
para toda la severidad de la enfermedad
causada por omicron aún no está clara en
eeuu causa casi tres de cada cuatro
nuevos casos la primera muerte por
omicron se acaba de registrar allí
es
improbable que sea más letal hay
evidencia desde las naciones de áfrica
del sur y particularmente de sudáfrica
que sugiere que debería ser menos severa
pero no queremos descuidarnos con eso
we don't wanna lenguaje
en días recientes corea del sur países
bajos alemania e irlanda han estado
entre las naciones que han re impuesto a
un confinamiento parcial o total u otras
medidas de distanciamiento social muchos
países han puesto en práctica campañas
de vacunación que incluyen una tercera
dosis en francia- un epidemiólogo dice
que no hay otra opción sino reforzar las
restricciones
dado que el virus circula mucho más y
que es más infeccioso si no tomamos
medidas de restricción fuertes
pensamiento social entonces vamos a
alcanzar el punto de saturación en los
hospitales
los países están considerando nuevos
cierres ante la incertidumbre continuada
y con el planeta ahora en la cúspide de
un tercer año de pandemia